Hello my name is Yvonne Honingsberg and I'm going to have a
conversation with Sunita Dutta for visible
lives in Oral History Project at the New York Public
Library. It is um June
seventeenth two thousand and fifteen and this is being recorded at
adds to Sydney offices. OK.
And now on to the questions.
So uhm tell me a bit uh about where you uhm
where you lived growing up and what it was like.
I grew up in Queens, New York
house and uhm my family ... What part of
Queens?  I lived in Hollis Hills. So uhm
it's like kind of on the border of Long Island. Uhm
It was like two.
I don't know, whatever.  You know, it was like Long Island was within
two miles from there you know and stuff. So, uhm,
Yes so I grew up there um.. my family
I have an older brother and my dad who's a doctor
smoker and we had a dog and
a very normal childhood.
My parents came from India in the early
sixty's and uh
so you know, uhm, you know
as a child, you know, it was kind of like a little
confused, like, in the way that, like, when I went to school, I was like, like everything
but, then going home it would be like cultural.  Yeah, was it very different?
No.
Very different, but it's, you know, it's like, you know, so like my
parents were like, a little bit more restrictive than other families
and stuff like that.  But not, that, you know, I mean, they did
socialize and stuff like that and it wasn't like I wasn't allowed to you know um
Other people or anything.  No, it wasn't like that. Did you grow up around
other Indian friends?
. Yeah, yeah like So it
was basically, like, during the week it was like a
normal kind of thing and then over the weekend, we went to other
Bengali families and stuff like that. And then we had like
Bengali school on Sundays and stuff like that.
so
So yeah. So it was kind of like a double
Yeah. But, you can verlay or other
people could relate to you - yeah - other
Bangali friends. Yeah yeah OK so
I know that you full disclosure. I know, Sunita, so
you went to school.  Ah uhm.
Press Corps. Yes, I went to undergrad to University
Michigan and then I went to Boston University for Law School and
then um I also went to
get my master's degree but that was after I became disabled
became disabled like a few
years after I graduated from law school. Maybe, like three
years after...three four years after and um.. Were you
working? I was working.
yea. And um
What kind of law firm. ok. So I worked in a medium sized law firm
I worked ?idea down? medical malpractice defense work so I represented
Doctors and hospitals in New York City. Did you like it?
I like it.
So when do you start having ?headache?
experience with disabilities of
well how did it happen um
Your disability? Well my disability started
in my consciousness it was when I had the stroke I had a stroke
in July of 2000 and
So yea
Like a few months before that or maybe like
four or five months before the stroke I did have an episode of losing
my vision for a period of like twenty minutes or so
and it could be related or it could could have been like if
they looked into it more or they would have known that I had
But that's like you know it's
Could of, should of kind of. But um so I didn't have any
thing before having the stroke. So when I had the stroke I went to the
hospital and everything you know happened um
the morning of the stroke um, I woke up in the middle of the
of the night and I felt like my leg was being a little funny
but I felt like I just like slept on it and I just got up and
went back to sleep. And later in the morning when I woke up
I tried to brush my teeth and stuff and it was just very funny and off
everything. So then that day I was
supposed to go to a client and uh
do a review and ?deposition? of somebody and
that um. I just felt really like my hand
wasn't working and stuff. So I called my dad in the morning
and I was like I feel a little funny um but you know
I try to brush my teeth and it was weird and
everything and um. He was like well you should go check it out and I was like
was like I'll check it out after after ?deposition?.
And he was like OK take down my number.
And if anything happens cause my dad is a doctor so he's very concerned
and so then I try to write down his number and I just
really couldn't do it he was like
Now call 911 and go to the hospital and I'll
meet you there
What did you feel?
Did you stay conscious? Yea I stayed conscious
And um how did your father
or your family deal and when did you find out
that I had a stroke? Yeah. Right away? Yeah
Within like a couple of hours you know.
So how long did you stay in the hospital?
um I stayed in the hospital for 3
weeks and then I went to a rehab in ?patient? for another 3 weeks
weeks
But um after being in the hospital, I had a second stroke ten days
days later while I was still in the hospital so and after the second stroke
second stroke was a lot worse
I couldn't talk, I couldn't do much and so
yeah.
Do you remember what you were thinking.
When it happened? Yea I was talking to a couple of friends that came
over and saw me in the hospital and all of a sudden
my talking became very weird and in my mind I felt like
I shifted to Spanish even though it was probably like
like ?Garbam? but you know
And then um. Do you speak Spanish? Not really
really I mean I had classes in Spanish and stuff, I can
you know but not off the top of my head or anything
So then um my brother came
he's a doctor also. And so he was like OK you need to lay down
be quite and let me get the doctors and everything and then you know
what was your recovery like?
things that you have to work on? Talking
occupational therapy, physical therapy
hand therapy and everything.
So yeah. So what was that like? Was it hard work?
Yeah it was hard work but you know I was very um
I was very.
I mean I worked hard they did everything they told me to and everything but I was very
resistant for things like be in a wheelchair and
be like no you know and they are like no you need to be in a
wheelchair and I'll be like all right if I have to have the wheelchair, I will take it
you know cause I was like there's no need for me not
you know what you know and so... But you
said ? I did it for like half a day
like why am I in it you know but like now like
now over the years I've realized that walking is very
difficult and so I get a wheelchair if I'm on the plane
I can't really walk throughout the entire airport and stuff like
that so I get a wheelchair and stuff..it's not that I'm resistant to it but they
wanted me like just to go down the block you know with the
wheelchair and I was just like whatever you know
Ok so you. And I'm like
one of the things was like
They fitted me into um something for my leg
Um and so it was just like
brace and a very bulky brace you know and I was like
I am not gonna wear it you know. They are like yes you do..
I was like OK whatever you know I let them do whatever they want
but what would I wear it? No. You were
showing your personality, you were not going to be a
my standard and for ?no care? No I mean I would do
everything like they don't want to but you know like you know
in my mind I was just like you know like no I did wear a brace
for like first couple of days or so you know
That's all. Yea so it was just you know
I just knew I'd rather
walk disabled than the brace
It makes for a nicer shoes. Yeah exactly.
How did you experience? I know your life after
After a year. Did you return to work?
Um I tried
returning to work but I went in and talked to them
I was like can I come back to work and everything. They're like
We're not sure.
I mean because I needed to talk to them because I couldn't go back
to my old status that was for sure and especially while I couldn't
really talk as well so you know and
and my you know I had to learn to write with
my left hand and everything and
walking was still fairly slow and everything so it wouldn't be
the same but you know like I could go back and
do um a lot of like I couldn't like
go to um court as much but I could do
do all the briefs for other journies and stuff
But they never really let me go
Go back and you weren't
.
I wanted to try but you know I
mean you know my job I
love my job I really did I don't put my firm.
You don't.
You know you know I was up a point when I was like looking to
move on to another you know for
sure.
Yeah yeah. Anyway yeah I mean how did
you do you are going any interviews yet
. But the stroke
really. Yeah. So.
After. I apply for a lot but everything's
changed and so you're.
Right after New Year's and like within like the next year
or so. So. I would say when they like
it here.
Like it took me a year to talk as little as I do now.
I still had patient moments for
you and.
Me. Faiza.
Very much but I've been after a year
it was I would be stuck on certain words and so I
learned to well it was like
.
You know it's like I was here.
An example is like I know in my mind I wanted my dad to
bring me a purple and black suitcase but I
would say you don't really need any purple but
then I'd forget what I just said and then I don't have to like start
over if you like and then I forget to say one of the
words and stuff like.
That and I think I can see it in my mind well exactly what I want but I
can't get the words out. His various frustrate Yeah yeah
yeah. And so you know. And you dare I say
I say I had a moment where I couldn't get the word out. But I
learned to lie. Describe what I want to even though I
couldn't say with precise order and then
eventually I would say maybe like when and like
three or four years. I wouldn't say any
more but it you know and I'll
let you know I mean I mean I guess I still do but you know it's not a big
deal in my mind and he will miss
his film is.
Set a year be years and years
for people.
Fun Day body change so much after the first few
months by apparently.
Yeah I would say so.
So I would say then like
the first year I probably didn't even try to work a brain
link after the first year to maybe two
or three years I am really trying to
get a night but I applied for different positions and still
get very far and I mean being
down.
So then I decided to go back and look and
.
See what I wanted to do
was like then I could go to a hospital and work for the
hospital in my
you know legal department in the hospital and stuff like that
so I had two Masters in Public Administration and specialized in
health care policy staff and then I got a
job not related to
them but it kind of worked for non not for I work
for a private organization where they had
my role. The company at home
. Basically all the medical
information for our hospitals
doing elective surgeries. So it was like making sure they
get all the required documents and everything and stuff like
that and it was there for like
two or three months to weigh in and then I think I
kept getting sick and sick and meaning going
into the hospital then like you know
it was like little you know it was
and I don't know why it was like I had There's something happening with my
teeth my liver or you know it's just like my levels were
off it. And another time I just couldn't eat and stuff like
that so everything kept happening and at that point
and. I was I was getting paid well and
stuff but at that point it was like it was like well you know it's like six months
into it and I was.
Also when I started on steroids and stuff like that because
that helped with my issues and
everything. So in my mind it might change my mind or something.
That's when I said you know I really thought about it and I said
I really need to stay on long term disability as opposed to
because I already did six months of it and in my mind I
did another six months. That would be it would be cut off completely. And
I said that might be a little too much of a risk because I kept getting
sick and stuff like that and so my mind said you know
it's better to kind of step back and really think
about doing it. So I went back to the job and I said
I'll still be here or else but I want to go part time and
don't pay me for a little while and then until I figure out what's going
on and everything. Because I wanted not
to be paid because I didn't want to get paid because it will go against the six
months you have so so.
If I have her find out while you were out. What are
you kidding me saying you don't want to say
so.
So let me go back a little. I'm one of the
reasons for my extra Oh was that I had and I said
which I never knew about that for you and
me. Basically it's an auto immune disease which causes
me to take in and that's causing a stroke. Then
moving forward there's a twenty percent chance of people with
it and therefore also have Lupus. So
so I don't know why it was lupus suspect
did it wasn't confirmed till a few years later
but I don't see what is happening.
So where do you have to stay on steroids all the time
so intimately I gained on steroids a bit of
settling for the first few years I would be on
steroids for me like six months or so and then I'd be
OK for another six months and then go back on and stuff. The
last time I was on heavy doses of steroids
for a good year but that was three years ago and
haven't been since. But you know it's just a
matter of time.
Yet I didn't say or keep but
how do you maintain it.
OK do you. Know.
I have always found it very very you know that
for us there right now.
Yeah yeah. I've always been that way.
I was always like a person like I would always
I wasn't like oh this like of course it all sucks
you know and I mean there's no thing about it but I'm not a person to
be like oh for me you know you know I don't
look at everybody look at me. Help me out you know just more like I
gotta do what I gotta do when I do I like being independent
and things like that and so you know I just go about
my weight you know. And if people don't like it they don't like it and I mean
you know and whatever you know. So I try
my hardest to do things and you know like every once in a while I go
through occupational therapy and stuff which helps out a little. You know
this is not a miracle cure or anything you know.
So yeah so.
When Morris the hardest task challenges
you faced and how did you get through them
. It's
like physically
.
The only way it was just like a question of like
getting things done it took me longer to do
today. And look I think you know
first it was like kind of scary to go on the
subway by myself and stuff like that.
But more so. In my
mind then things like that. So initially after the stroke
I have to move back in with my dad for a year
and even after a year if that's what I like was like
moving back in there. Living alone you know when you fly do you really
think you can live alone and I was like I'm not sure but I gotta
try and stuff like that. And so yeah I work out and
stuff but you know it was like a big process like in the wake of like
you know me and my dad had a discussion you know it's like.
Well let's just say you know do you know
do you really want to rent a place like you know and
so like I was like yes I would love to own both what if I can't
live by myself and then you know and then he was like.
OK so you don't buy a place but I mean if you
can't live by yourself then you want to rent it out and you
know back home but then it was like you and your co-author condo I mean it
was like well if you can only stay there and you want to get out then you
need to get a condo vs
. Oh you know it was all these discussions. Then
it's a financial issue. Everything said you know you
dig up.
I've got no condo. Yeah. So because I wasn't sure if I could
really live alone you know what it can live right now
and then the other thing was like. OK So if you're going to move me you gotta know
like I used to live. In a lock up.
And I couldn't live there anymore so you know I was like
Yeah you know it was like I need it
going on but I needed assistance a lot of assistance so I needed
to be in a false and doing stuff like you know who will or
if anything happens I'm fairly comfortable
and fairly sing you know and stuff you know see
how you are in a leadership role and you know.
Yes on my condo board. Far
are you. I'm on the board of Sydney. Yeah you know so
well are.
You going to my condo board or.
Anyone else likes the flick like
.
I would say seventy years at least and I think on this board
have been released five years or so that you get on
me for that hey so if you want.
Yeah no no that's fine. So after I had my stroke and
everything but before I went back to school I
was probably like year two I guess
I am I. One
tear for him for some wine
bottles Carlos is society.
And I got that mom that said at the time which was like of the
hand assistants and stuff like that so they're
like you know work part time. You see
what you can do you know things like that and so I
volunteered in the legal. Department and the
Multiple Sclerosis Society in New York and I met
my friend right now. It's my boss at that time
and she is on the board of me
and so did her.
I mean there are times when I see her.
Yes so what.
So I was going to offer you as you many questions like
can you tell me I'm an experiencer to bring you the word
turban too and not let the stuff you already
read it didn't even think about it but he used
the word stop right to your day to day did
you have a time when you had paused to
work to even think about it you
know what I think is going on buses
a lot of money issues at first for like the first
couple years was like.
It's like OK so I'm disable and I'm
entitled to sit in the disabled spots but
it's like where people look at me really funny
and stuff like that and I just like and I think that you know I
felt bad for sitting there and stuff like in my own mind goes like
do I really do I get up and let somebody else
take this you know and and so it's been a struggle but
you know like I'm more comfortable now and people
will approach me and be like why do you sing the you know the
light and sometimes I got up and then they'd be like oh yeah you know who it
is they're you know and you know who have been getting it right
now I think now that I'm older too because I was only
twenty eight at the time and you know why younger an
hour already. And so you have
to deal with it. Yeah you know a long time.
Yeah I. Know you've heard things change. In
addition to that with your friends or family
or community have handled things
evolve.
At first it was everybody was like
hovering over you like everyone kind of like
just wants to protect you but you know
you know there's only there's only room for so long people can do that.
As much as they want to but you know it's like it's not like
they can do that for a year and then you know and then
that's what it ends up happening everybody wants to protect you and make
sure you don't like have any ill feelings and stuff like that but
you know as time goes on you're going to have to realize that you do
have to deal with it a lot in everything when they're not around.
Right right and so you know it's so I am a person who is just
like I'm going to live as you know. Because you're not going
to change my personality or anything you know
. And as much as I like people like my family would love to
love to see me more are you know not as I once am I have
spoken
. But a person.
Tells it as it is. Basically I'm not like I'm
not a very real talk about person. But if I'm
interested I'll say what I need to say
.
I think you're quite OK.
How so and you know you had a stroke.
Many years ago now. So what experience
.
Do you have right now do you feel like
you are in the display community or have you
program for a year now and I still think the
Liddy community because one physically because of my
stroke but also because of Lucas so I've kind of you know like
and looked as I say I don't know if it's technically a disability
or not and in cases it might not be and in other cases it
might be going on.
There's always concern in my mind like there's always going to be
something you know. Yes I feel fine today but that
could change at any point.
You know and so I'm
in my mind I see myself as disabled because there are
certain things I can't do stuff like that but you
know. Other times you know
.
I'm more comfortable now saying I am disabled and I am you
know it took me a while to be OK with being
a disabled person but you know it just it wasn't like a
given day here on Earth would be like to have any or
anything but it just you know it took me time to you know
come to terms with everything.
Hell are you asking for help.
Prior to fly home I do ask for help when I
need to but I try to do it for
myself. A few different times and then if I really
can't then I ask for help. So how are you with
people offering you help. So it's really funny you know.
So I met this so I wasn't dating for a really
long time after the stroke and I was like
not in the mood for anything. And. I
saw this guy on the street looking at me and I was just like forever
and so and then he kind of looked back
at me and came up to teens like Are you OK and I was like yeah I'm
fine.
He was like Can I walk you somewhere and we were right outside of my
building and so I was like I live here. No you know
and he was like.
Do you want to go somewhere or you can use like you
want to go get a drink or something and I was like why would I go you know it's
like I don't know you. And.
Yes why not. You know and that was like a moment in my
mind where it was lying. I really couldn't
answer him. I really didn't have.
An answer to him and so then you know I went with him and whatever
he we became friends and and it was just like
kind of like a stretch.
Yeah it was just like a slave and nothing major but you know it
was just like he goes long enough you know and that was
just in my mind it just was like oh yeah it
is interesting because you were always taught since
childhood to go and you know I think I
hate it I mean I and then I mean sure I
was you know it. Yeah yeah.
And I didn't let him get into my apartment. Haris Yeah
yeah.
OK he has don't you find it yet. Oh I know
because I was going to bring up. OK OK so very
different way here.
Very difficult but you know
I do mean anyone are
like so from two thousand and
one to maybe two thousand and
eleven. So you know that's a long time
. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah. And so you
know and then then I started dating a little
on line and everything but I'm
OK You know this is you know I was dating a little bit online
. I met someone.
You know and he's very interesting. But it just never
really worked out and stuff.
Do you tell me before that
you had to deal with that.
I so I did and you know I had it on my profile listen
I'm not one of the person who.
It's not that I'm very upfront about it but like
dating I just felt like they should know like I don't want to have to
kind of beat around the bush with anything so I just put it
out there you know and if they have a problem with that they have a
problem with that you know. Yeah so yeah. But then
you know a lot of people ask a lot of questions
about it. And in some ways that's fine but that in other ways
it's like why did it really matter.
You know you know like you know so
yeah
. So. Why do you
think they do. Right.
There you go out by the very last page
and I say I don't know dating someone who
didn't really have a disability but he well
he went through.
He had some
kind of medical issue and stuff and it's only really
to make you
.
Do something. Yeah that's right yeah. And so you know we
relate it to it and it's. Why yes but I can't
believe I mean we just casually nothing like me
. And then I did a little bit more time. There
are scammers on line and everything and so you know it kind of did it for
a year but then it never really came to fruition it was more like
talking to people on the phone but actually physically meeting I don't know
if it really worked out you know and then and then you know
talking online I mean talking over the phone and everything. After a
while they forget about my disability which is
great but then when we me they're lying confronted with
this all over again and so it's like what do it do
and it's all about me it was kind of nice when I saw that guy on the
street and then I mean he came in my mind it
was like oh right i was like OK so maybe it's better for me not to be
online and just me. People went on about you know
sex and yeah but you know you know Dating is
hard.
Can I just ask you why it didn't work out
was presented to you. As a success. Let me tell you
why. They didn't have any taint what it
is now.
Yeah yeah I think yeah I think once you mean the
right person I don't think the
disability go away you know
and you know like they know your
condition and everything and they accommodate that so the disability
part of it will always be an issue but
the relationship doesn't you know change in the light. Like
when I met the guy on the street it was like.
So you know like when you meet me in general now it's more
closer to me like within like a year for three years as
opposed to going you know closer to where he
lives or wherever you know. But other than
that the reason you know that he's a cop.
Yeah yeah and yeah OK so
yeah but you know like you know like I said I don't let anybody
stop me doing what I do you know. And so like
for example I went to I go to the U.S. Open once a
year and everything and so. I don't usually go
in but I can't really walk around so I usually get the
results here it takes me to the sea and then
they you know after it's all done they take me and drop me off at the
entrance to the U.S.T.A. and then you know it's
like yeah you know like celebrity you know no but you
know it's like.
I think I did walk in. The first
year and it just was really tiring for me and so
then like and then like the next couple of years I kind of
try to avoid trying to go in and just do
like one. Just like just to go one place
you know and it took me a couple of years to be like
OK All right. Yeah and
you write on vacations. Yeah yeah and
so yeah when I go on vacation I go with a couple of girlfriends and
stuff and they're all walking in everything. I get a
scooter. So you know I don't like so for
my fortieth birthday we were in Miami and they could all
walk around and stuff
. I guess that aren't so I could just be with them you know and then I
had to give you know my walking is
incredibly slow so you know like come.
Like walking down the block takes me like a minute or two as opposed to
most people just like me.
Yeah OK Well yeah. It
sounds to me like you. Right right right
right right
. Yeah but I mean you know I do. Over the years I
tend not to use the subways.
I mean I do it at times when I need to run stuff but I don't in
general I will prefer the buses over subway
cars going up and down the stairs is a lot because of my stroke
and because of my lupus their tires me out.
It's hard you know it's hard to go down the stairs
. I don't have a problem go up stairs down the stairs is but you
know it's just like I think you know and so I didn't
go home in the subway like you know a few times you
know but you know after all.
Not on the subway stairs but I didn't
fall on the street once or twice since that way.
Especially when I was on steroids and stuff you
know.
Yeah yeah yeah it happens you know it could happen to anybody.
Yeah yeah yeah all right.
Yeah and it happens because
I'm cautious unconscious so yeah
I sound like you know you're I mean yeah yeah
yeah. Is that part of the acceptance because
maybe. Yeah I think so. You know
so I have this and I get extremely tired at times
because of it and I plan on schedule and I
do things but I try not to make my
schedule and pack you know everything in one day or anything.
So I try to like be like I try to say like in my mind I'm not going to
do more than two activities a day and then even then
I you know I really try to plan like one day where I have
nothing to do. Like somebody like have a day where
I'm water in my one class
. So yeah you're
like oh. Yeah yeah you know
because you know on some days it's like I'm just so tired you know
. So I don't really need to wait just a day just to do
nothing and went day in and rested
. Yeah yeah OK So
listen I hear bucket list I'm thinking I don't know maybe
you checked some of them off or
run off or you know and I knew I would like to
travel a little bit more.
Where. All human hands. Yeah you know I'm going
to you know but I want to go like I would love to
do a trip to Europe again and to other places
that I haven't been you know where are the other places on
I think I slept soundly and Paris.
I would love to go to
Asia or you know I've been to India you know but I don't want to go to like
Thailand or China or something.
So yeah I can connect so
well and so I would love to hear places
you like to go to.
OK I'm sorry. I forgot to ask you about
tearing
. Oh yeah yeah and so you say
interesting. Yeah. So as I said I was a lawyer
and after I stopped working after
getting my masters I still wanted to do
well here in things and so
one day I was home watching Dr Phil of all things
which I don't really like but he
he talked about Casa or witches.
It was basically to volunteer for kids in the foster
care system in color and kind of her
that kind of interested me and so you know I applied
for CASA CASA is short for a court appointed special
ed kids and so on.
So I applied and they went through their training and everything
and now I volunteer for kids in the foster care system in court
which I really like because I used to love going to court and being very
caging for people who
are again there are more kids usually I
don't know much but usually when the judge
the attorneys the caseworkers and
everybody I don't know what you did to the child
at times you do see. I've definitely seen
parents and I've times I've met the kids
but they're not usually here in Port and a lot of the
stuff that I do I can do from home so it's a lot of phone
calls and making sure people get things done. So
the court assigns us these cases
and it's little we kind of so you know
like the case workers have their own perspective the attorneys have their own
perspective and so because it is kind of like where we
can kind of see a whole picture kind of like the eyes and
ears of the court and so on.
You know it's like we call and follow up on all of these to make
sure everything has to be done you know where it is you know OK
so this is look this is all I can do you know and then turning I'll just say
that's not my goal though it's kind of like bridging the
gap between so
do you find it every morning.
Very well you know what are.
I like being active I like the fact that
.
People can rely on me you know I mean I don't do much
but you know like it's nice talking to whoever it is and they
like want to get information and and and or
they're a person who can't really get that information and it's very important for
me to get that information and get it out there for them and stuff like
that.
Yeah and it's very rewarding when you know I see
am I here.
Case closed for a while ago but he ended up
he was in foster care and he ended
up being adopted by foster parents and stuff like that and I was
there things that were in their.
Hands or a tactic.
Yeah well maybe but you know the other thing I
really like about it is that it isn't my case.
But I also have a supervisor and any time that I
get sick or if I can't do anything it's going to conquer
everything and so it's like you know for me that's very
helpful because there are times when you know
.
You know I get sick and I can't do you know and I'm not
as effective and stuff like that so it's really good to have the back up you
know. Yes sorry. Yeah it's very reassuring. And it's not like
we're And all of us. It's nice to be part of an organization
where you know. You can do that you know and
it's not something that's like a full
time job or anything so I get like two or three cases a time so it's like
you know ends up to be like five to ten hours you know for something
so yeah it's just right for you
. Yeah yeah.
Sounds like you have so much more time on
the board and see me and so I feel like between those things and
it's you know it's a good mix and it's also like my
like illegal things I do cause
things like my condo work because I live in that community and it's very fulfilling to
me and for Sydney it's like I try to raise
funds and stuff like that so yeah
yeah.
There advocate for the disabled.
Yeah and you do you stay in touch with
your all that or oh yeah
yeah yeah I mean there are some that I lost you know like
it's just I'm you know not being in touch and stuff but
in general yeah OK. Yeah and that happens that
everyone you know disabled or not you know
but I've lost very few friends because I'm disabled
but your personality Yeah I have
gained a lot of more friends and I have very
good friends from growing up in a big thing and then have
a few college friends and everything
and you know.
I guess the biggest part of losing was
. More of my law school friends
. That's a question of the way just
because I don't More
own work related you know.
So I'm not really in that. You know. Are you here
. Yes. But I do have I have
friends that I used to work with that are very good friends
. So so people lawyers
like my own old office need an old
office around people that I used to hang out with after work and
though they are still good friends and until and we still go
out to eat or whatever come to their marriages and
stuff like that yeah yeah.
Yeah yeah.
So anything else you want to stay
for your experience. It's their partner.
It sucks to be disabled. Oh it's no fun
but I also think that getting
past it is all in the mindset you know it's like
you can be a miserable person where you can do something about it
and I've always been a person who is like I'm going to do something about
it here now instead of just being poor.
You know from the get go yeah yeah Hear
hear. And did you have any new role models to know
how you know on the railroad. Any support.
I'm sure I did. Yeah it was a while ago.
I'm you know I mean I think that person has
.
The Multiple Sclerosis Society was a very good role model for me
and you know you saw her with her
disability and stuff like that and I
respect her tremendously and stuff like that
.
And you know I think
you know in talking to friends and family and stuff it's
just being normal just talk you know and I
don't want to try to make it so. There was
nothing they shouldn't talk about you know. So like a lot of people end
up like I don't want to be like Let's talk
about her disability but not in front of her or anything like that.
Yeah yeah I like that. Yes I was just
like come on now ask whatever you want you know.
But times you know some people you know
tend to talk too much and they're like OK heroic stuff
you know and stuff.
Yeah. OK so.
Are you selling yourself in
T.V. or do you really
.
Think you so much for the interview.
You know OK I found more things.
Speaking as a single person myself
I'm curious to know I think you're steaming
interested meaning
somebody yeah but. How do you deal with
me so far right then and go
Oh yeah yeah yeah. Answer part of me is fun
to go on but I don't work I love to know
how you deal with kissing me. Well
yeah let him leave already.
So you know as I
said before dating is very awkward at first and everything
just saying I have no issues with all of that I am a person who
loves kissing and and and you know I
think of you know the writing how to have
less
. Right.
Exactly but you know
getting more intently is very awkward. And
I'm still not very good at it
.
You know and honestly it took me
from two thousand and one and two
last year.
Right did not have sex whatsoever. But I did
have times when you know we fooled around and
stuff like that but we didn't actually have physical
sex. And. And
since last year I've had a few times
but it's still a little
awkward to me in the way and really in the way
I like different positions and
stuff I really can do a lot in that it's like
you know it's like OK the guy who have to be on top of me.
Yeah yeah yeah and they were right happening
. They do yeah well you
know and.
First. Partner I had he was very
good and in the way he was disabled
also very different than me so it wasn't a
physical Well it was you know but he
was more on the line now you know so it was in
position ing things you know but it also
that first time he made me feel good about it in the
way like OK this is normal you know and so
yeah yeah and so on. And since then
you know I'm here and still
you know depends on the different people you know and you know
so I still don't have them
. I still don't have a
lot of.
Some the sex that I've had it's only on
occasion and then we're going to be with the same person like maybe like
two or three times and then they just dissipates and so I'm
still not good in
having a good
sexual longterm
person so I'm still struggling with
. Well I mean as for
it being so many who will be right for you right away
and said oh you know but it has to.
Did you break up because you know it's not going to break up or
I think it's just it's just yet because it
wasn't like.
We were dating to begin with. You know it was more
like. You know we're having fun when we when we
go out. For a couple of times but it's not like
he wanted to get up to be my boyfriend or anything. So yeah
there was.
Yes you're right and I am and
I still struggle with the real
intimacy of you know the relationship and everything
.
And so he does or now
I just lanky in my mind set
and just being physically intimate and alone.
Yes I would love that with you know so people but it's just not
happening and so I have to struggle with that reality
you know.
But I'm hopeful you know
. Right right right
. Well you know yes so that's something that I've
definitely.
Struggled with. That you know if you're not lying
to your wife to do it.
Yourself. Right. Yes but I mean I still
feel awkward. You know what I mean. I just I don't know.
How too late do it now I mean I've
had sex and stuff like that but it's like I just don't know
how to work on how to
pursue a relationship
along to please him you know
because.
But it is that because of your spelling or is
not really.
Having much it yeah I mean
you know it's not anything to do with the disability but it it's always come
down when the.
Yeah I mean I think it's more in general just
meeting the right person and stuff. Yeah yeah
.
Yeah.
OK thank you so much for being here so
soon.
OK OK OK OK OK OK.
Thank you I am part of the engine here and
I know why
not.